[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
michael rosenbaum good afternoon ryan
tears good afternoon on the hottest
frigging day
it is
here in los angeles folks scorcher just
a scorcher uh thanks for making this
podcast yours uh if you're here for
brian baumgardner i i really hope if you
really like the interview you'll give
the podcast a chance and subscribe and
uh follow us on our handles and write a
review it really helps the podcast with
a little podcast that keeps going
somehow thanks to all the people out
there who are supporting the podcast and
my lovely patrons uh what are the
handles here ryan inside to be pod on
twitter inside of you podcast on
instagram facebook that is correct and
just a few shout outs uh my good friend
shira austroff uh at the animal rescue
mission they rescue rehab and find
forever homes for abused and neglected
animals
uh check them out they're just uh
they're they're an awesome awesome
non-profit
www.theanimalrescuemission.org if you'd
like to donate tell them old rosenbaum
sencha also echoes of hope for foster
youth and foodonfoot.org if you want to
support homeless i'm a part of that
organization and the ronald mcdonald
house of course got a support
um you know not a lot going on in the
con world until november i'll be doing
that but uh just a shout out my my buddy
rob who's in the band's son spin with me
our album's coming out in a month so
keep going to sunspin.com
uh there'll be merch soon we've got some
cool stuff coming i believe calendars
and mugs we're gonna make some t-shirts
the new album is pretty great go to
sunspin.com you could book the band you
could uh zoom with the band um support
us i really appreciate all your help on
that and if you want any cool merch go
to the inside of you online store we've
got
scripts
small those scripts signed by yours
truly lexmas we've got smallville
pictures we've got inside of your
pictures mugs
tumblers
uh we've got so many cool things
so do that and if you want to join
patreon to help support the podcast
which so many of you do
it really truly keeps this podcast going
go to patreon.com
inside of you patreon.com inside of you
and i will give the shout outs to all
the top tier patrons at the end of the
podcast so make sure you listen
and uh that's about it we got a great
guest today you know from the office uh
what a kind guy it's my new bff
i just love this guy i love having him
on he was uh
not only funny but he was he just
kept it real he's such a he's just a
sweet funny
informative guy
then you enjoy it i did i wasn't there i
missed it i wish i was there oh yeah
jason was here i know jason was here it
was a really great time i really love
the podcast yeah i think you're going to
really love this podcast and i'm also on
his podcast so after you listen to this
you could listen to me on his i think he
asked me some of the same questions i
asked him on purpose let's get inside of
brian baumgardner it's my point of view
you're listening to inside of you with
michael rosenbaum
[Music]
inside of you with michael rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience
2003 2003 yep i bought my first house in
la in 2003. really
yes
and i bet it was about the same and uh
how many years did you live there
well it was small
yeah so not that long
um
[Music]
not that long it was
i mean it did well in a short period of
time maybe it was two thousand it was
probably 2005.
but yes and then i lived um
i lived east
uh bronson canyon
for about 10 years you liked it i did
yeah but you lived alone or you had a
girlfriend at the time yeah no i had a
family and i um
yeah it was great and then i started
having kids
and decided that it wasn't for me so
went to
san diego you know uh you're another one
of these guests that i say occasionally
when they come on the podcast
that people like you you're a likable
guy
it's just my friend was at a they have
these office conventions okay we're just
there okay right and she was there and
she's more into animals animal rescue
she has the animal rescue mission oh yes
i met her shira shira yes yes who um
this is going to be so is that we're
recording right sure yeah i know we are
this is gonna be so embarrassing if
she's listen what did she play on the
office i i don't remember the role
it was a girlfriend of of uh
reigns
early on in the show it was like an
episode where she was like the uh some
girls that he was dating i think she was
in high school or maybe it was oh yeah
it was weird it was weird it was either
rain or it was kazinski but i think it
was i think it was rain interesting okay
but anyway she was there she was there
they asked her
she's like what the hell she had well
they weren't her dogs but she was
helping with the dogs right yes so do
you go to a lot of these cause i go to
comic conventions cons like eight or ten
times a year do you do a lot of these so
i don't
you don't no
but
i
more just because i feel like i have to
i just i'm on the road a lot these days
and so i sort of have to
budget the time that i'm away so like i
had not done anything since covet
started
right so that's
already nothing you didn't do
that's three years
or you know so like the beginning of of
you know the end of 19 beginning of 20
something like that i i did one that was
the last one i had done prior to like a
week ago right
it was crazy do you like them i mean do
you like the attention do you
no that's not that's not really my
that's not really my
thing i i
look i thought it was super cool and
what is amazing about the office fans
is
and i and i have said and it is true
like the best gift that i have been
given from the show is truly
how
being able to experience from the inside
how much the show means to people i mean
like truly
means to people and
and it's bizarre because i i try to
think of myself
and
and and translate
their love for the show in me for
something else
and it's hard for me to find but what i
what i'm talking about is like people's
desire
and and need to tell me
how much the show has meant to them how
much the show meant to them
in a really
dark time in their lives yeah that the
show brought them comfort that brought
them made them feel better
um healed them in some ways and i mean
you know military veterans or people who
have the same thing yeah gone through
an incredible loss in their life or a
medical condition and and that they want
to tell the story
and so do i like it i mean it's
draining it's very dry it's very
draining it's amazing but it's also like
when everybody's doing it you're like
you want to give them the attention you
want to give them the love and you're
just like oh my god i'm just i'm so
exhausted exactly and
and i know that that sounds like ho poor
you having to sit there and listen to
people
i know it's crazy but like that because
that was an office convention right
i think it was slated to go from nine to
six that's yeah and i didn't
take a lunch break i didn't i did not
leave
because of the people waiting for every
last i was there until about 8 15. yeah
i think it's a it's a beautiful thing
when you connect with someone and they
tell you what the show meant to them and
you you know you're surprised you're
like how could this
something that was just funny and goofy
and we had fun i was getting paid for
how could this mean so much to you
but then when you you try to wrap your
head around it it's kind of it's a
little confusing but it's also a
beautiful thing and what i meant to say
is not that it's like you get drained
it's just like
you know you do a podcast for an hour
right you don't want to talk anymore
right right i don't want to do more than
an hour with you
it will not go over an hour right so
imagine you're there for
nine hours of talking to people right
it's just naturally you're going to be
exhausted right
right yeah so it's but i
it is
um
it does mean a lot to me sure it really
it really does and i think that
specifically
the show in a lot of ways how it was
constructed
um you know i've talked a lot about this
on my podcast
when i talked to
the other cast members that that i sat
down with one of the questions that i
asked everybody was about the last line
of the show
and what that meant to them and clearly
greg daniels the creator wrote the last
episode so he wrote the last line and
the last line goes something like
um
why did they decide to do a documentary
about a paper company
well i think it's a great subject
it's about beauty in ordinary things
isn't that kind of the point
and i think that that celebration
of the ordinary for the office
that sel that
these people have meaning we spoiler
alert we weren't like friends right like
we weren't like on the cover of cosmo
and doing all of the glamorous stuff i'm
talking about the actors too who were on
the show right we were a
group of ordinary people who were
assembled by a great casting director to
work together in this place and
and that celebration i think is what
what responds to people yeah did you uh
you auditioned for the office right i
did how many times
you know i think it was just twice it
took a long time
for a decision to be made but i think i
think it was just twice
i hadn't done anything at that point
nothing
well yes so i i had i was very very
very new to los angeles so like i didn't
know out you know allison jones had a
stable of
comedy actors that you know she was
watching for years at ucb and the
groundlings and all those places so i
wasn't that
um
you know i had to
convince them to let them see me
um
but yeah i mean i had a lot of
experience in theater and character
creation what about improv were you big
enough no i wasn't see that's great
because i auditioned for the office oh
you did way back when
as what year did it start well so
the the pilot
was
um the pilot was shot in 2004 right
yeah i read for it i don't know it
didn't go any further right
but weird i mean weird i just i'm here
right now i'm talking to you it didn't
go anywhere but were you surprised did
they ask you in the audition to do any
improvisational
uh pieces or like they say hey just keep
going keep talking um
not so much for
me in the audition though i kind of did
they um allison jones is brilliant
um but they had me reading for the role
of stanley right and i knew the british
version of the show and i knew this
character that they were calling kevin
here was the part for me so i read
for the producers i read stanley as
though it was kevin
really yeah
and i left the room and was like i don't
i don't know how that
went and allison ran after me and said
hey there's this other role we want you
to
we want you to read and so then i went
back in
for kevin
um just just just
cold
cold dish yeah i mean she probably said
here take 30 minutes or you didn't learn
the lines but you kind of just read off
and think yeah yeah
yeah and then
daniels was he in the room daniel did he
just give you a smile
was there anything that kind of kind of
made you feel like i might have died i
don't know
you know i don't know
i don't remember any of that i i don't i
don't remember any specific
feedback except a feeling which i'm sure
you've had which is like when i left i
went
that that went well like that went i
don't i mean probably at the time
because i was so new i was probably
thought i got that
right and now it's more tempered now i i
know enough to know that like
oh i'm in the mix for sure and they may
choose
you as opposed to me or they may choo
you know
a different color or a different flavor
a different you know type person um
but i yeah at the time i i knew that and
you know what i don't know if i don't
know if you ever heard this
i uh
i
it was down to three when steve carell
left the show allison jones was looking
through
the memorabilia for steve like was there
something from his first audition or
whatever
and she came to like his party when he
was leaving and she pulled me aside she
was like i didn't really find that much
for steve but i found this i thought
you'd be interested and this was like a
paper it had been
seven eight years kind of
discolored i have it in my office now
and it just said kevin malone
and
it's in my office but i don't remember
the order it wasn't in order but it it
said one two and three brian baumgartner
eric stonestreet
and jorge garcia
so at that time that's before lost with
jorge that's before modern family with
eric in there
there i am and wow rain wilson always
says to me too bad eric didn't get it
because i'd be much richer now if i had
gotten minor family but um
yeah i mean i think it worked it worked
out for everybody wow
now a word from our sponsor better help
better help i don't know what we do with
that better help uh you know i
have been lately dealing with a lot of
anxiety and what happens is i hyper
focus on all these negative things ryan
that keep spiraling and i can't i can't
it's hard to focus it's and it exhausts
me and
gives me anxiety
and these thoughts kind of just and i
know it's not i shouldn't be thinking
all these things and i it's like in my
mind i can't put it to rest a lot of
times
and um
you know it can be tough to to train
your brain to stay in problem-solving
mode
and
you know especially when you're facing
challenges in life and i know that
therapy
helps that
talking to someone and having them
talk to you objectively about what works
trained professionals helps it just does
i
doing it on my own isn't working it's
just not working
if i don't have someone to talk to i
will just continue to spiral there's no
way out
that's how i feel
do you feel that way
yeah
um you have to talk to somebody
you know
people always say well how'd you get
into therapy
it's because i just couldn't solve these
problems on my own
i couldn't you know it's you could say
you're going to do these things and
you're saying oh you what happens is you
just bottle stuff up folks we just
bottle things up
until it becomes very toxic
and our body feels it physiologically we
feel the effects of
you know pain depression anxiety and it
takes a toll on your mind and your body
and that is why i got into therapy
and i'll tell you a lot of times i have
nothing to talk about and for the first
five minutes like why am i here what am
i doing and by the end of it i'm like
thank god i'm talking to somebody my
lord look if you're thinking of giving
therapy a try better help is a great
option ryan here does better help it's
convenient accessible affordable and
entirely online get matched with a
therapist after filling out a brief
survey and switch therapists
any
time
you know a lot of times people are
selling things and there's ads you have
to read
to me this is the easiest read ever
because it's just something i could talk
about forever
and
look better help is is a great place
it's a it's a place to to help a lot of
people when you want to be a better
problem solver therapy can get you there
visit betterhelp.com
inside today to get 10 off your first
month that's betterh-e-l-p-com
slash
inside
inside you is brought to you by shopify
folks you know without shopify you know
the the merch
would be so much more difficult if you
wanted to get merch or anything that i
sell here on the podcast and i couldn't
do it without shopify if you don't know
what shopify is listen up because it may
very well help you in your business
whether it's a small business whether
it's a big business
shopify gives entrepreneurs the
resources once reserved for big business
so startups
upstarts and established businesses
alike can sell everywhere synchronize
online uh and in-person sales and
effortlessly stay informed scaling your
business is a journey of endless
possibility when i first started on
shopify i had one t-shirt and now i have
like 20 or 30 items
it tells you what items are selling best
how much you're making at the end of the
month which aren't selling well uh just
how you do from year to year it's so
easy to use
it's the basics and it does everything
for you
and they pay you on time and it's a
wonderful wonderful thing believe me
like this like i said this park podcast
started selling very few things and now
uh it's uh it's a very big success and a
part of the podcast and i i need it um
shopify powers millions of businesses
from first sale to full scale reach
customers online and across social
networks with an ever-growing suite of
channel integrations and apps including
facebook instagram tick tock pinterest
and more
gain insights as you grow with detailed
reporting of conversion rates profit
margins and beyond more than a store
shopify grows with you this is
possibility powered by shopify connect
with your customers drive sales manage
your day-to-day shopify instantly lets
you accept all major payment methods
supercharge your knowledge your sales
and your success discover endless
possibility shopify is tirelessly
reinventing tools of growth for millions
of businesses helping them succeed every
day discover inspiration shopify
believes in liberating commerce for all
because entrepreneurship has the power
to drive communities forward and
commerce can be a force for good go to
shopify.com
inside all lowercase for a free 14-day
trial and get full access to shopify's
entire suite of features grow your
business with shopify today go to
shopify.com inside right now shopify.com
inside
inside of you is brought to you by
freedom grooming where was freedom
grooming when i was doing smallville and
i was bald
ryan this product is fantastic
at freedom grooming we make the flex
series electric shaver which is uniquely
designed to flex and contour to the
curve of your head for a smoother faster
and safer shave without the risk of
nicks cuts irritation or ingrown hairs
where were you where were you freedom
groom and now you're here ryan it is the
smoothest shave of your life
flexible blades contour to the shape of
your head for a baby smooth shave every
time i know this because my friend joe
tells me and it works amazing and i'm
sort of jealous of him
shave 50 more hair in a single stroke
compared to traditional razors expect
shave times of two to three minutes not
10 to 15. never cut yourself shaving
again the flex series safeguard
technology means no nicks no ingrown
hairs no problems and the flex series
waterproof design means you can shave in
the shower with or without shaving cream
shave wet or shave dry since even the
sharpest blades dull with use freedom
created the close shave plan with a
close shave plan you'll never run out of
fresh sharp blades delivered to your
door every six weeks with free shipping
all active cloche plan members are
upgraded to a lifetime warranty and it's
completely customizable adjust skip or
cancel your plan anytime we have over
ten thousand five star reviews so stop
deli slicing your scalp with traditional
razors try freedom today or get it as a
gift with your exclusive 20 percent off
by going to freedomgrooming.com
slash inside that's
com
freedomgrooming.com
[Music]
inside
i mean when you were
there nerves when you were first doing
the show and you hadn't done much like
you said except theater do you remember
being nervous on set you remember being
like i'm out of my league uh how'd that
feel yeah i remember
i remember the pilot and
angela
angela kinsey and oscar nunez and i had
a
very short scene in the pilot that we
were shooting and
you know it was shot at the end of the
day
and
we
left thinking okay we may get fired like
really
yeah like there's just not enough they
show what you could do yeah they're just
what yeah that's exactly right and so we
were like trying to make this
meal out of what was a very very simple
exchange that should have been delivered
simply and um and i think that
you know
looking back i think it was
much more about
what happens in pilots which is just the
everybody feels like everything has to
be perfect
everything has to be exactly right oh
yeah and
so i think it was much more about that
but at the time we were just thinking
like
how did we just spend an hour and a half
on this like
whatever like three or four line
exchange and
we started improvising pretty quickly
and i think we know about it i think
so what happened was
there were characters from the british
version kevin being one from keith was
the british character but greg daniels
always knew he wanted a larger
um
a larger ensemble here so like oscar
talks to me a lot about in his audition
he improvised a lot um because
he you know he i think he read for
stanley as well or or read for somebody
else didn't get it and they were like
but we like this guy let's find out
who this guy can be
so he did a lot of improv i think angela
um angela kinsey as well
which is good because they you know they
have i mean they're incredible
improvisers right it's weird though now
michael cause i
um
that's what people see me as
is like a comedy improv guy right just
on the surface and that's really not at
all
what i what i was what i did i was like
dark theater dramatic like
horrible characters trying to find some
sliver of humanity and the like darkness
um
but you know now it's like oh no you're
a improv guy right you're a comedy
improv genius exactly you're one of the
biggest shows ever made right exactly
were you a regular did you sign a deal
for as a regular or were you a recurring
and became a regular after
the the so the first season which was
only six episodes
we were all recurring except for you
know four or five guys
um or four or five people um
and then we were made regulars right
well tell me about
you talk about the dark stuff and the
theater stuff and all that but growing
up you grew up in atlanta atlanta yeah
were did you have cool parents were they
together were they cool parents great
people loving loving
very loving very supportive
oddly of you know the path they told me
the story
later
so i
graduated i graduated from
college and i started doing theater and
i went and joined a very small theater
in minneapolis minnesota
and
the
first show
my parents supportive
flew to minneapolis
um
they told me they told me that they told
me that night this story which was they
got into a cab this was before uber they
got into a cab from their hotel and gave
the address
of where the performance was and the cab
driver said you don't want to go there
oh no yes that's where you were doing
your theater yes apparently it was not a
great neighborhood and they were like no
i think we do um
and it was it was february right and i'm
from the south so
like it's cold intensely cold weather is
not something that my parents or i were
comfortable with
and
they show up i think there was a
discussion of cancelling
the performance because i think there
were like 12 people in the audience
including my parents
and it was like
like freezing
and my parents didn't say anything that
night
but
years later probably after the office
um they came and said you know
we had a we had a ride back to the hotel
after this which was like
what the [ __ ] is he doing he's a smart
guy why is he doing theater this is
horrible he's here
nobody's watching like what is he what
is he doing
to me they were really supportive and
great show you know everything but like
between themselves when they got alone
they were like oh he's made a horrible
horrible mistake he's made a disastrous
error did they try to tell you at all
during this whole process of you
becoming an actor
hey have you thought of maybe having a
backup plan
you know there wasn't there really
wasn't much of that i mean i was
um
i decided
early meaning just like
like everyone goes to college right
thinking you're gonna major in one thing
and you end up majoring in something
else i mean this is this is like a part
of life
and that was not me i mean basically
from
the summer before my senior year of high
school
i
knew this is what i wanted to do
and i was i was singularly
focused on that so like i went to smu um
which at the time and i think still
you know i i did i didn't want to go to
like a juilliard or a carnegie mellon
like i wanted to go to a university and
at the time
i believed um that smu was the best
training pro conservatory training
program in the country
that was within a university like i went
to us came out to usc and there was
northwestern and a lot of
places that people think about like
northwestern people sort of think about
theater or usc ucla out here in la but
smu to me was the best and that's that's
where i went so i had like a
you know a very singularly focused
college career and then beyond i never
sort of wavered were you popular like
growing up
i was i was never a theater kid
i don't i i never
so like i wasn't in a fraternity but i
was hanging out with all the fraternity
people real smu yeah
did they go see your shows
yeah
yeah they did really yeah and they were
supportive they were supportive yes
because like i loved sports so like i
wanted to be going to the basketball
games and the football games weren't
great but like i wanted that colle i
wanted that college experience yeah um
and not just in fact i remember getting
um because the the theater department
was was insular in a lot of ways and
there was like parties but they were
like the theater parties and somebodies
yeah um and i remember getting [ __ ] late
late you know junior senior year like
you don't ever go to the theater parties
like what you know you're what you're
just like too good for us or you're like
blah blah blah and i was like no no it's
not that i just have i'm spending all
day every day with
you know all of you i want i don't know
i want like um you know a wider
breadth of experience so
yeah my friends uh by and large in in
my
well that's not true i have a lot of
friends who are in the theater
department still
um but i had a lot that was outside for
sure
inside of you is brought to you by
conair
uh you know what i hate going to the dry
cleaners i'm flying a lot ryan i go all
over the place and my clothes are always
wrinkled
but not anymore ryan
no not anymore
uh
the conair turbo extreme steam steam and
iron two in one it's the most powerful
handheld steamer it's so easy to use and
so small you could pack it in your bag
and travel with it and you never have to
worry about wrinkly dinkly clothes not
anymore fast and easy wrinkle removal
extra large sole plate can be used
vertical or horizontal also works
without steam as a dry iron advanced
heat technology is ready almost
instantly and obliterates wrinkles with
turbocharged dry steam
four settings for delicate to turbo is
perfect for all fabrics
kills 99.9 percent of all bacteria
sanitizes around the house and refreshes
clothing easy to use
great for at home or on the go to get
yours today go to amazon and search
conair turbo extreme steam and look for
the steam and iron two in one did you
know a fire department responds to a
fire every 23 seconds
october is fire prevention month um you
know it's just right around the corner
and it's never too early to start
preparing and we have teamed up with
first alert the most trusted brand in
fire safety to help protect your whole
home and safety you can trust smoke and
carbon monoxide alarms help provide an
early warning in the event of a home
emergency having enough first alert
smoke and carbon monoxide alarms is one
of the best things you can do for your
home and family install alarms on every
level and in every bedroom of your home
now once alarms are installed it is
important to maintain them by testing
them regularly also remember alarms
don't last forever and need to be
replaced at least every 10 years they
are on duty 24 7. if you cannot remember
the last time you replaced your alarm it
is best to replace the unit completely
along with alarms fire extinguishers are
essential make sure to place fire
extinguishers on every level and in
common spaces like the kitchen and know
how to use them for more information on
fire safety products safety tips and
educational activities you can do at
home with your family visit
com
firstalert.com
fire prevention month
firstalert.com
fire prevention month
the theater department i don't know if
you folks out there listening know but
it's very
clicky very very
very judgmental very i mean they're
thinking everybody's judging them
but really they're judging i remember
being a part of it it was just like
everybody was out to kill each other yes
and it was like oh yeah what's up there
was a couple guys a couple little
friends that you have but you know when
you saw those names of who was cast in a
play
oh i saw some looks like are you [ __ ]
kidding me rosenbomb what the [ __ ] is he
doing he sucks
you know did you experience a lot of
that um
yeah i mean it was
it i mean it was
i never really talked about this
but i mean in truth it is i mean it was
pretty
cut throat e and not it was always
very sort of outwardly supportive and it
was a supportive department for sure
but
you know they
were a premier theater training program
and they let in 15 act this is a
freshman year 15 actors
and 15
others
and they called it theater studies so
that was directors designers writers you
know all of that and there were 15
actors by the time we graduated and this
wasn't there weren't cuts you weren't
like eliminated like a game show
but by the time we were done
i'm guessing there were six actors seven
without counting in my head right now so
i mean it's just like people are like
okay this is not for me right which is
what happens in college all the time
like you think yeah
major in
economics and then you
discover pr or whatever i don't know i
don't know what do you major in i don't
even know i could not come up with two
majors to make that example
um
no yeah it's right yeah that's true yeah
i had a teacher
professor dr whitney combs doctor dr
whitney combs and i remember the first
time i took basic techniques of acting
my freshman year okay still talking like
him
and i'm sitting there in a classroom
and he gets up and goes
um if you're here for uh just an easy
elective
please raise your hand don't be afraid
please raise your hand if you're just
here
for a free
it's an easy elective just raise your
hand and i i was always a goofy kid i
was about i was like seconds away from
lifting my hand up and i didn't and then
about seven or eight people raised their
hands like yeah they're like now if you
quickly leave my classroom
they're like what no seriously get out
of my classroom and he kicked those
people who just wanted an easy hey
out of the classroom and then afterwards
he stopped me
mr rosenbaum
and i go yes he goes i was wearing a
mets cap and a mets jersey i didn't look
like a theater kid i look like a punk
and he's like do you really want to be
here and i go
yeah yeah i do
i didn't know i wanted to be there i was
scared shitless i had an audition for a
theater for a play then and
he kind of shook his head it took years
i wanted him to make you know i wanted
him to like me and eventually i started
to do plays and build up the confidence
and he took me aside at the end and i
said should i go to grad school and he
goes i think you're ready i think you
should go to new york and give it a shot
and i did he was one of the few people
that really was like hey you've got this
that's incredible it was incredible did
you have someone
for sure
who was the who was the mentor who was
the person that you remember that goes
they're giving me the confidence dale
dale moffatt dale moffat dale moffat
yeah he was uh for a long time began to
transition out but was the head of the
acting
uh program at smu
and i mean
my the difference in in my story was
exactly i'm sure the same but because it
was a conservatory
you had to be one of those 15 people to
be in the class right right so if there
were there was no like that wasn't an
option and that's what i mean like we
were in
you know you usually you're going back
and forth across campus taking different
classes we just moved on mass
from
you know voice and acting to movement to
you know theater studies and you know
blah blah so yeah so that was the that
was the difference but yeah no he was
the one
who
i mean i guess what i would say is that
i had good instincts
and i had an experience bef
[Music]
the summer before my senior year of high
school where i went to northwestern
actually and there's like this program
and it's one summer
for kids it's called the cherub have you
heard about this the chair program oh
yeah at northwestern for incoming senior
students in high school
and it's it's intense
like
i don't know six eight weeks but it's
like theater and was and it ended up
being akin to my experience in college
but that's when i went and it it was for
me like
i'm confident on a stage i feel like i
you know i understand
basic you know
i don't even know what i would think at
the time like and you're only like
motion or 18 yeah like emotional
whatever and this was like
oh no there's like a process
for like actually do figuring things out
and doing the work i mean like being an
act like and that's what opened my my
brain to it so i feel like when i went
into smu it was it was all instinct and
then by the time i left it was like oh
no okay
so if i'm given a character and i'm
reading and beginning to assess like
their needs their wants what they do to
get those things i mean basic actor
stuff but being able to deconstruct a
role or a play
and and if you're having trouble this
moment doesn't make sense to me being
able to figure out what that is as
opposed to kind of skating through it
and waiting until the next thing i
understand so which i think people do a
lot yeah so you think you can't just go
become a great actor based on just your
instincts
do you do you need that's a hard
that's a tough question right that's a
really tough question i think that you
know for me
and i you know i mean
i'm not saying something like
revolutionary i think if you look at
at my work for example
like you see it right there
um
there is for me the construction of
character is really important
and finding
who that person is
um and and that
voice and
body and movement and rhythm and pace
and all of those things
um
help to make up who that character is
i'm creating yeah there's
just as valuable you know like uh
i mean harrison ford for example
harrison ford is spoiler alert i'm
looking because he's got a strategy
right here
he's not he's not transformative right
right he's he's essentially harrison
ford right like right i mean he's not
he's not he's not brando or
you know de niro or you you know and not
that but he's not
so like does he just have incredible
instincts i don't know i don't i don't
know him personally i don't know what
his process is right
but you know um
but for me it's about it's about using
all of those tools that i have now
to try to
completely
invent in every way who this character
is how they're the same as i am and how
they're different so you're doing all
these plays in college right yes and
what happens after were you aspiring to
do film and television or was it theater
something you just wanted to do for the
rest of your life no i was just talking
to somebody actually emmanuel shriki
on my podcast about this that for me it
was only theater it was that was all it
was
and thinking back because i just had
this conversation with her on the
podcast that i
i can't i don't even
film and television never
it just almost wasn't even a something i
thought about wow
never i really that's crazy it just
seems to me that every actor wants to be
get an oscar every actor wants to get a
you know it's like i have to admit like
when i was in college i was watching
tarantino movies and going i like
theater but man i want to do movies i
want people to see me i want i want
yeah i mean
i definitely
i don't know i think for me that was
just not that it wasn't achievable it
was just not something it was not the
path that i was on i guess
and maybe i just did maybe i just sort
of thought like oh that's for later or
something like
and
um
here's a story i don't think i've ever
told
and harrison ford now it's all coming
back to harrison ford
i had a friend who i met in chicago in
the cheer up program before my senior
year we stayed friends
um and she had moved to la and she was
actually on a television show
um and
um
[Music]
she became very good friends with
calista flockhart's
best friend harrison ford's wife
harrison ford's wife
and i
she invited me to come out
to the premiere you could figure out the
date of when this was i'm gonna say it's
circa
1999 or 2000. okay the premiere of i
think midsummer night's dream she in
mid-summer midsummer night's dream the
movie i believe it's a midsummer night's
dream i'll just forgive you if you're
wrong it was um
invited me to the premiere
and i was at the premiere
and my friend lived around westwood
and so i was staying with her around
westwood
walking through westwood going to coffee
bean
for the first time
the weather was amazing and going to the
premiere and faye dunaway was sitting
right behind me
and i
truly i that for me was like
oh i like it here
i want to be here now really that was it
that feeling that was the it was like oh
no this is i belong here and
i grew up in atlanta so that was my
homie i was born raised
through high school that was my home and
i as i was doing i was in you know
dallas and then minneapolis like i said
i was kind of based in minneapolis and i
was traveling around and doing theater
in all these places i was like a
regional theater actor so i would go
where the work was and
um
but i was i never had a home for for
sure i never had a home and i visited
here on that trip and it's such a cliche
now right it's like well yeah you were
at like a humongous premiere you know
they rented out in westwood
you know like an acre of land and turned
it into the forest it was midsummer
night's dream right yeah it was
midsummer night
99 in 99 that's this [ __ ] steel trap
of a memory right there in 1999
midsummer night
and so it's like oh you're out of
premiere and there's fey done away like
of course
of course you're gonna be seduced by it
but i was like oh no this is where i
need to be and so it was at that point
that i started
um
i started thinking about law just being
in los angeles um and you know three ish
three four years later i
i finally made it do you ever get star
struck
besides faye dunaway
i have never seen faye done away since
by the way um she is awesome
um for me
it kinda you know i was lucky so early
i mean first off i saw
carell
turned from
one of us to something
not
right i mean like right at the beginning
of the show
just before the you know we've done six
episodes and 40 year old virgin comes
out and like he's literally the biggest
comedy star on the planet at that point
um i worked with robin williams a few
times
and so like pretty early i was you know
um
i was i was mad and introduced and so
that and that never did it for me um
jack
nicholson yeah when did you meet jack
because i've met jack a few times
at the lakers out of lake that's where i
met him too yes i was in the back room
with jack nicholson
in that back cigar in the cigar room
that was it i was yes
yes that that was where it was well i
was there and i was sitting there
talking to him
and i go man that's a shame you know
they need shaq to be back in the game
because he was injured or something he's
like yeah well you know it's like if you
know he starts talking about this and
that and everything's fine and we're
having a nice conversation about the
lakers and the season he doesn't miss a
game and and all of a sudden this guy
comes up to him and goes hey jack this
game isn't as good as it gets is it and
he goes if you'll excuse me and then
[ __ ] and i looked at the guy you [ __ ]
i was just talking to nicholson you
[ __ ] it up you [ __ ] up my mama with
nicholson he goes jesus dude i'm so mad
i know exactly what you were talking
about because for me it was very similar
and in fact
there's a the in the in the bowels of
staple center by the way he's referring
there is a room chairman's room there is
a room and there is a cigar room within
the room which is if you're in the room
where it happens then there's another
room that you don't even know that
exists for a while yeah
and i was in there
uh i was in there
and and my buddy was with me at the game
and there's also like
very nice bathrooms back there oh yeah
in the chair and so my i said i'm going
to go in and maybe have a little cigar
and my buddy says i'm going to go to the
bathroom i'll i'll i'll meet you in
there
and it was just me and jack yeah it was
it was just me and jack and my buddy
later tells me the story the the door
into that room is a swinging door like
it you know it swings both ways like a
you know at a at a restaurant between
the kitchen and the and the thing
my buddy describes as like pushing the
door like pushing the door
like to walk in full speed
seeing that it's me and jack
and slowly backing away and shutting the
door and he gave he gave me that moment
he was like i'm not gonna screw this up
i know how he feels about jack
i'm just gonna i'm just gonna what did
you say i'm just gonna back away
uh it was it was
it was largely the same
uh we discussed the office very briefly
mostly about the lakers i want to say
this was
our the the bulk of our conversation was
about bynum
uh andrew bynum wow center for the
latest in the past yes um that had some
great games and then had some not great
games that i believe that was where the
conversation was focused and
um we bid each other goodbye and then i
you know we sort of
did a hello
uh several other times after i used to
go quite a bit to the to the lakers
games as well but um
yeah for me that that was that is it i
mean i think i think for me probably
that was it too just meeting jack
nicholson because he's he's got to be my
favorite of all time yeah and it's just
it's being a movie star
he is he that is right he is
he but and and i don't mean any
disrespect to like someone like
and so i'm not speaking of this person
specifically but like there's like i
guess now it would be like tom
cruise-ish like movie star but there was
something about jack
that he was so good and so
transformative in so many different
roles
in the shining and one flew over the
cuckoo's nest in chinatown and
all of these movies that he was just so
amazing in and at the same time
he was jack like before there was the
one name thing existed
he was just that and you know i read
something this is years ago so i'm sure
i'm getting it wrong but it was like the
the director
camera shot to jack at the oscars like
somebody had gone through and counted
how many times right like the host is on
stage or somebody and they like just
they just
cut to jack and you know like code him
and it was like the most cutaway shot in
the history of the oscars by like a
gajillion or something that's scientific
um
yeah so but there was that in the
sunglasses and the courtside at the
lakers game and yeah there's just this
this
feeling of like whoa like i think when
he when he's around it's like
everybody's like wow that's a star it's
just you know uh
what was i gonna say
about jack nicholson oh there's this the
shining documentary did you ever see the
shining documentary i don't think i did
stanley kubrick's daughter i believe
vivian kubrick okay shot this
documentary of the shining it's like 30
minutes
and it's like jack brushing his teeth
and he's like
yeah i don't know if people really want
to see this is this interesting i don't
know and then they just they follow him
around as he's getting on walking on set
he's like all right here we are we're
going in this room now and we're you
know and he's he's jumping up and down
getting ready for the big here's johnny
yeah you know and it's just awesome
how could you have not seen that i
haven't seen it you guys got it listen
you have to find it um it's on the
shining um extra stuff uh it's it's
superb
but uh that's that's by the way i'm a
big horror fan and the shining is
probably my favorite horror movie of all
time
i think it's mine yeah for sure what's
your favorite line in the shining
oh man mine's really weird oh man
i don't i mean here's johnny comes yeah
i mean it's so iconic you just said it
though so that's why i'm thinking that i
should say something else oh no here's
generally no i literally am like i
should say something else
um
yeah there's the there's the moment on
the stairs well there's the moment on
the stairs but
um it's not even him but it's the it's
the bartender lloyd lloyd lloyd it's
like
you have always been here right like oh
that's that's that's the caretaker uh
grady grady great yes yes
yes yes yes you're the caretaker yes
you've always yeah yeah you've always
been the caretaker yes i didn't quote
that line well but that my room that
line still just shivers
just yeah what the [ __ ] is going on i
think my favorite is when um
uh she goes up to jack
uh shelley duvall's character what's her
name
wendy wendy she goes jack
jack someone's at the hotel someone's
here at the hotel they hurt danny
and then he turns around and looks at
her and goes
you out of your [ __ ] mind
that's probably my favorite moment
because it's so non-sequitur just weird
no i i know i know my favorite moment
which isn't a line is when the camera
comes around
and you see
all work and no play makes jack a dull
boy
millions of times in that on that
typewriter boy was that that yeah that's
my favorite moment whether you see me
typing whether you see me working with
you you don't see me working
you do a really good job i know that you
know this i mean i do i don't do it a
lot but i do love nicholson thank you
thank you yeah but it was a it was an
opportunity i mean we were talking about
nicholson we were the jack i got it um
you have a book well first of all you
you're a new york times best seller i
mean wow
that seems like an impossible task your
book welcome to dunder mifflin the
ultimate oral history of the office was
a best seller yes how many copies did
you sell what do you have to how many to
be a bestseller i don't know but quite a
lot
geez were you are you like surprised um
yes in part i mean i i i mean i think a
lot of times as we were talking about
earlier you know if you build it they
will come meaning the office fans and
but i
we were
we the book launched on
because i was in scranton i went to
scranton
and signed copies of the book in
scranton and i'm going to say that was a
thursday or friday evening the book
launched on a tuesday
and i started getting text messages that
the book was no longer available at
amazon
this is like three days later and i was
like oh how many sales do you have for
amazon to text you
this book is no longer available i know
i don't know um
but which was you know it had been like
months of it not being available right
like it's like pre-sale available this
date
and then so quickly after it
after launching for it to say that i was
like oh no no
get them more books where are the and
it's not quick to reprint books by the
way no
it's not um
there were some more somewhere but like
amazon's entire allotment which i think
amazon is huge you know you send a lot
of books to amazon it was gone um it was
it was a lot of fun the whole experience
of of getting the gang back together and
and and and telling that story and for
me it
was truly
for me it was based on a question
because it was some conversation about
doing a podcast and telling the story of
the show and
and
how do we do that and
you know i've never really been into
like
presentational type stuff or like let me
explain to you why
we or us were so brilliant um
but
you know we were i kind of referred to
this before but we were the number one
show on nbc
for most of the time that we were on so
ten years nine seasons the first two
we struggled mightily um
but
for most of the time we were on but we
were never like we never thought of
ourselves and i know that our collective
experience
was in the nbc
you know pantheon of these shows so like
seinfeld or cheers or friends for sure
we were never that
we were like
a solid hit right now for nbc that
doesn't have a lot else on the air
that's truly how we were treated by nbc
and that's that's what we were um
and
then
three four years ago now
streaming numbers start coming out
and
my experience walking through an airport
or being out in public
suddenly is way more intense than it
ever even was back when we were on
thursday nights every wow
and that was the entire experience of
the book of starting the podcast was
really based on that question which was
why why
why is this why is this happening
because it is one of the biggest hits in
the history of television well now
now
more people are watching it now than any
other show in television like think
about that that's insane so you know you
still have the cover what stranger
things or you know
whatever the hit streaming show of the
moment is
more people are watching the office that
are watching those shows still
that's remarkable it's in i know it's
insane and so that for me was it which
is what why is that why why is this
happening what and can we go back and
can we deconstruct
decisions that were made that maybe have
made it
yeah and not just survive this long but
actually now be thriving again
like michael we were not making a show
for kids this was not a call this was
not a conversation yeah like we were
like oh if people who work in an office
can maybe relate to it then we'll be
okay like we'll stay on the air right
and
but like the kids are watching it it's
crazy
that is just insane uh the new book
you're releasing your second book a
seriously good chili cookbook yes in
september
uh i didn't know you were you're
like your character you're a chili
aficionado i'm a chili aficionado yes
the character is and um
has become a
a big
meme
gif gif gift chef yeah
um you know it's just become one of
these
one of the moments from the show and so
i
you know i think the first couple of
times was really like
let me let me do it for the gram right
like i'm gonna make some chili and take
a couple pictures and
this will be fun right um and then i do
enjoy cooking i i i love to cook it is i
would love to taste it
i mean
don't just even
say it like that i mean
but you have compiled that says
177 of the world's best
chili recipes from celebrity chefs
restaurant owners chili cook-off winners
dedicated fans and of course himself yes
that's crazy i so i have my own recipe
they they have the the recipe from from
the show or or best their best guess of
it but know so a year or so ago
i went this is a thing that exists and
not only does it exist
it's like
i should have done my research it's like
60 years
give or take a couple of years
the world championship chili cook-off
exists in this country sponsored by the
international chile society it's been
going around 50 to 60 years
and
there's a competition
for like world the world champion and so
everyone who is there
is a winner right like everyone has won
they're local they're firehouse the you
know the firefighters have one there's
um you know their region their state
their whatever and there's like a
hundred of here there's a field and
there's just people cooking chili
everywhere
and you're like tasting it and trying to
evaluate it and
and i judged it
um and it was a crazy
crazy experience but so much fun and the
passion that people have for i think
because it takes time and i think in a
lot of ways the longer it takes the
better it and so it becomes very
communal it becomes very family whether
that's like your actual family or like
the your friends or whatever the people
who enjoy it too
um it's something you share i love it i
just there there's the culture of it i
love i just love and there's like beans
or no beans or you know greens meatless
and meat and turkey and this it's a
million ways you can get a milk yeah
well there's at least 177
177 that's fantastic um so yeah i i i
had so much fun uh putting that together
and uh
yeah coming out coming out september
13th a seriously good chili cookbook let
me just ask you is
your chili would you think it would
compete with some of the top chili
makers in the world
yeah why not
yeah
i mean i don't mess around how long does
it take you to make a bowl of chili um
well
you know typically you make a pot of it
not just a bowl um can you imagine just
you're literally
chilling you're literally just measuring
out enough meat for one bowl
um
i would say
i mean there's a certain point in time
where i do think like the longer you let
it go
for my recipe the longer you let it go
just the better it is if you have more
time so like ideally i'm starting late
morning and
gonna do it in the evening and just let
it just just let it just just get all up
in there and just [ __ ] flavors if you
ever invite me to where you live for
some chili i would go okay if you ever
have a party chili party or chili party
chili gathering okay
please uh this is called by the way the
podcast off the beat podcast yes how
long have you been doing this
so i
um i have been doing a podcast or
another now
we're at about three years and what i
what i mean by that is i started with
the office folks which were really
taken from the interviews that that for
for that book but like i had
corel for three hours i had greg daniels
for i think four and a half hours or
whatever and i sat down and we recorded
all these conversations and then we
released those
interviews and not just them but like
the chairman of nbc and designers on the
show and writers and directors and um
and that was really about
again trying to figure out or at least
come up with some
answers to why the show is so popular
now
um but you know there's a limited number
of people who worked on the office right
i just started loving doing it
and so i went to i heart and just said
like i want to keep going and they're
like go and so now it's really
my goal is sort of the same it's just
now much more individual which is
is about it's called off the beat
because a um a director and theater
director that i used to work with that
told me that
all great comedy happens off the beat
that there's an expected rhythm which
you could call the sitcom rhythm but
when something truly surprises you
when something changes
what that expected pattern is those are
the that's when it's truly special and
so for me that's those are the moments
that i'm trying to find you know we're
talking to
emmy winners and you know athletes now
who have you know won mvps and super
bowls or whatever but i'm really
interested in those
moments that happened that started them
on a certain trajectory
uh that changed yeah that changed where
they are
um
and and what they become
that's cool very it's really cool thank
you off the beat podcast thank you
listen to it folks i've got some really
loyal listeners they will listen please
and if you ever need a guest man all
right
you're it you're in i would do it you're
in i have i have a sort of an
interesting story yes i think i don't
know clearly
this is called [ __ ] talking with brian
baumgardner this is uh my top-tier
patrons get to ask questions okay this
is rapid fire this is the end of the
podcast coming up rapid fire so i should
answer as quickly as i can you can but
if you want to elaborate you feel free
you don't have to rush through it you're
like i really need to get out of here no
i don't know i'm trying to understand
the rules yeah there's no rules really
it's like you know you could rapidly
speak or you could take a moment
uh but go to patreon.com inside of you
to to join patreon become the family
i'll send you a message after i
appreciate the support for the show it
really really helps the podcast all
right
chris r
um i know you just released a chili
cookbook which we just talked about yes
so i gotta know which recipe is your
favorite
you know how you're gonna give that you
know i well i will say i i i'll say two
one mine
obviously
two i would try um i am i'm not gonna
pull her name right now but last year's
winner of the home style division um
which basically means with beans
i
in the preliminary rounds
i tasted her chili
passed it into the finals
as my favorite and it ended up winning
the entire thing so
one i was pretty proud of myself for
being able to that other people agreed
with me yeah and two it's absolutely
delicious so uh the home style winner i
know it's there uh i apologize for not
remembering her name but from 2021
the ics world championship chili
cook-off try that one for sure wow emily
s is there anything you would change
about kevin your character in the office
if they gave you a chance anything um
i wish he'd had a longer
term
romantic relationship
fair enough
sophie m do you have any fun stories
from your episode on screen queens
[Laughter]
so that's from sophie that's from sophie
sophie thank you so much for the
question
sophie i don't really i don't so i don't
i don't really i
i mean i had a good time i know that it
was it was fun it was entertaining
uh those guys
can be really good and i don't really
have a memory i'm sorry
leanne
what or who inspires you
jack there we've learned that jack
inspires me um
honestly
i still love
creating characters i still love that
and getting a script
and particularly now
being tasked with a
a character that i haven't done before
or i haven't done
to the masses before you know maybe
something i worked on in theater and
it's been a number of years and being
able to go back into it and do that that
that would be that really
inspires me and and gets me really
excited
maya p what is the best game of golf
you've ever played i shot 72
once
i was uh the course was a par 71
and
i was under par on the front and my
brain couldn't even comprehend that that
was the case and so i thought
that i was already one over i'm lipped
out a putt and then only later realized
that if that had gone i would have been
even um but 72 that's my best have you
ever
finally have you ever dealt with any
like anxiety or depression or issues
like that for you cause you seem kind of
a happy guy guy who has it together but
has ever been ruts in your life where
you just you couldn't get it going
um i've been very lucky in that regard
um i mean look everybody from time to
time
has difficult times that's not something
that i've particularly struggled with
no i and and and so i my my i i'm not a
good person to speak to it
um i
i guess i'm just lucky
what do you do to stay kind of like your
mind just golf for real you golf a lot i
i mean i try i mean to play a lot but
that for me
is oh
it's i
and the reason why is because i i am a
i am in some ways a micro manager
right like in terms of my business and
um
you know i i'm always looking at every
angle and my brain will sort of like
spin like that um when i play golf i'm
thinking of really truly for those four
ish hours i'm thinking of one thing
which is trying to get this ball in the
hole your mind doesn't wander and it
really doesn't and i and i also to the
frustration of of people i now my
manager i tell him
i'm i'm i'm i'm checking out like i mean
i tell him where i'm going right as
opposed to like trying to hide it or
whatever because i really try unless
there's something urgently happening to
not look at my phone like i just i put
it away
don't look at it anything that helps
significantly a hundred it helps me
i think it would help everyone
shut your phone off every once in a
while and just go do something and
forget about
[ __ ] you know that's i mean for a lot of
people it's hiking right or or something
like that that takes less time generally
than than golf and i i know that it that
it takes a lot of time but i'm i am by
nature you know i played sports growing
up i'm competitive and so that that kind
of drives me yeah to do is like no i
want to play better i want to do better
i want to hit a better shot and and you
just every shot there's a there's a
potential for greatness and also
and horror and shittiness yes
self-loathing and all that but at least
it's just about this game and at the end
that that is i will say i will be
incredibly competitive and really in it
and five minutes after we're
you're over it oh no i'm totally over it
like yeah i don't go home
yeah uh the book coming out is a
seriously good chili cookbook comes out
in september uh the podcast is off the
beat podcast brian baumgarden this has
been a real treat for me dude so much
fun thank you so much thanks for
allowing me to be inside of you today
i enjoyed it
me too yeah
there you have it uh i hope you enjoyed
that one i don't know how you couldn't
have
was just a damn good interview wasn't it
i hope you liked it brian's uh he's a
mensch and i love doing his podcast and
uh thank you brian for coming on the
show
i appreciate you it was a long drive
from wherever the hell you live you
can't say because he doesn't want
anybody to know where he lives
but not close you know that i live in
the hollywood hills hollywood california
uh just a big shout out to the other
podcast that i'm doing now with tom
willing and ryan here as a part of that
and that's called talkville
and uh we air every wednesday we watch
every episode of smallville and then we
critique it the next day
so you will hear what we think of the
episodes there's a hotline there's a
bunch of cool stuff there's some merch
coming out and uh
exciting stuff so i appreciate that and
if you want to support that podcast you
go to patreon.comtalkville
and support that one so uh that's about
it i think it's time to do what we
always do it's uh
the reading of the top tier
by the way i had my mom in town
yeah yeah
how was that
it wasn't easy
was not easy um
i love my mother
but uh you know
she's i don't know she's uh
she fell a couple of times
and uh
it was hard i mean
i want to see her healthy and happy and
that's what i i want
but uh i wouldn't say it was the most
fun that i've ever had
my anxiety was high
here's the shout outs
nancy d leah asks sarah v little lisa
yukiko jill
he brian h nico p robert c
w p p
b
jason w sophie m kristen k raj c joshua
d cjp jennifer n stacy l jamal
f correct janelle b kimberly e mike e l
don soprano 99 more ramirez santiago m
chad w leanne p janine r maya
p mattie yes belinda and nice chris h
david sheila g brad d ray h tabitha t
tom n liliana a talia m betsy d and by
the way i want to say thank you for
everybody i see a lot of names on here
that are also supporting talkville and
it means the world to me so thank you
for supporting not only inside you but
the new podcast as well i mean it means
a lot to
to me and tom
uh chad l marion dan n big stevie w
angel m rhiannon c corey
l k damn uh dev nixon michelle k
a a jeremy c andy t gabbanado david c
john b brandy d camille s the chief joey
m design otg eugene and leah nikki g
corey kdb heather l jake b mel s orlando
c caroline r christine s sarah s eric h
shane r emma
shane r emma
r
jeremy v
andrew m zatoichi is that oichi 77
oracle chris r michael f karina n
michelle d amanda r amanda s
gen b and kevin e those are the top tier
patrons thank you all from the bottom of
my heart thanks for listening to the
podcast uh every week um i'll keep going
if you guys keep going
from myself michael rosen i'm here in
the hollywood hills of california
hollywood hills i'm ryan tez a little
wave to the camera we love you be good
to yourselves folks be good to
yourselves and we'll see you back here
for uh
the next episode of inside of you all
right talk soon
[Music]